GO AHEAD AND START OUR HEALTH
COMMITTEE HEARING THIS MORNING-
WE HAVE ONE BILL BEFORE US WE
WILL HAVE TIME LIMITS WHAT
YOU'RE WITNESSES- AS THREE
MINUTES PER SIDE EACH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES BE ASKED
TO STATE THEIR NAME IN THE
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY THE
THERE ARE BECAUSE IT IS ONLY
ONE BILL- SO THERE ARE NO
PROPOSED CONSENT BILLS- THE
BILL IS AB FOUR NINETY FIVE-
I'M GONNA SPEND SECRETARY TO
TAKE THE ROLE STATUS QUIRK.
WHAT HERE MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW RIGHT BONTA BURKE. RIO
FLORA LOW MOAN. MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN PRESIDENT RAMOS
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON. WE
HAVE A QUORUM- LAST MISTER
MURATSUCHI TO PRESENT HIS BILL.
THEY ARE NOT THERE. NUMBER I AM
HERE 2% EIGHTY FOUR NINETY FIVE
THE TOXIC FREE COSMETICS ACT- I
WANT TO THANK OF THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'VE HAD NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS BILL-
OVER THE LAST A YEAR AND A HALF
THIS IS A TWO YEAR BILL AND WE
FIRST PRESENTED IT AS A
INFORMATIONAL HEARING- IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE. WE HEARD
THE- OPPONENTS ARGUMENTS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE MATT. IN
ALL CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE
REYES WITH US. THIS BILL WILL
BAN COSMETICS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT CONTAIN. ORIGINALLY TWENTY.
AMENDED TO THIRTEEN AND WITH
OUR AMENDMENTS- THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING TO BE TAKEN IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BUT
ARE NOW AND FRIENDS AND THAT I
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE ARE DOWN TO ELEVEN.
TOXIC CHEMICALS WELL KNOWN WELL
ESTABLISHED BY THE SCIENCE TO
CAUSE CANCER REPRODUCTIVE HARM.
OR HORMONAL DESTRUCTION. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TOXIC CHEMICALS
THAT ARE WELL KNOWN TO BE
HARMFUL. ORIGINALLY WE HAD LEAD
MERCURY ASBESTOS FORMALDEHYDE.
BUT IN ORDER TO RAISE THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION. WE
ARE PROPOSING. AND TO HAVE A
LANGUAGE TO THE EFFECT OF
TAKING OUT. AS BEST THIS AND
LEAD IN ORDER TO MEET MY
COMMITMENTS MADE OUR COMMITMENT
TO MIRROR. THE EUROPEAN
STANDARDS. SO ANY CONCERNS
ABOUT ANY TRACE AMOUNTS THOSE
ONLY APPLIED TO THE LEAD AND
ASBESTOS. AND SO THAT IS NO
LONGER AN ISSUE. THESE TOXIC
CHEMICALS ARE SO WELL KNOWN
THAT MOST PEOPLE'S REACTION TO
THIS BILL IS WELL AREN'T THESE
CHEMICALS ARE READY BAND.
UNFORTUNATELY RECENT
DISCOVERIES OF COSMETIC
PRODUCTS ON STORE SHELVES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. HIGHLIGHT THE FAILURE
OF EXISTING CURRENT LAWS AND
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THERE WAS A
SPECIAL IS FOUND IN CHILDREN'S
COSMETICS PRODUCTS BEING SOLD
BY POPULAR RETAIL CHAINS LIKE
CLAIRE IS AND JUSTICE. TO
RETAIL POPULAR RETAIL CHAINS
THAT TARGET GIRLS TEENS AND
TWEENS. I KNOW ABOUT JUSTICE
BECAUSE MY TEN YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER LOVES THAT STORE AND
THAT WAS. YOU KNOW ONE OF MY-
ORIGINAL MOTIVATIONS IN
RECOGNIZING YOU KNOW WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT THAT WE NEED TO
PASS THIS BILL. IN ADDITION WE
HAVE HAD NUMEROUS INCIDENTS.
WELL DOCUMENTED OF BABY POWDER-
CONTAINING ASBESTOS FACIAL
CREAMS CONTAINING MERCURY. HAIR
STRAIGHTENERS CONTAINING
FORMALDEHYDE A RECENT STUDY BY
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH INDICATING THAT.HAIR
STRAIGHTENERS AND FORMALDEHYDE
HAS A STRONG- DRAMATICALLY
INCREASES THE RISK OF BREAST
CANCER ESPECIALLY AMONG AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN. SO THE SCIENCE
IS CLEAR ON THE HARMFUL NATURE
OF THESE CHEMICALS AND WHAT WE
ARE PROPOSING IS TO ALIGN THE
SCIENCE WITH THE EXTENSIVE
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH AND
STANDARDS THAT ARE READY EXIST
AND THE EUROPEAN UNION. SO THAT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS HAVE THE
SAME RIGHT TO THE SAME
PROTECTIONS THE SAME TOXIC FREE
CUT COSMETICS AS THOSE ALREADY
SOLD IN EUROPE. IF THEY COULD
BE SOLD IN EUROPE. THEY CAN BE
SOLD HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I'D
LIKE TO TURN. THE PRESENTATION
OF THIS BILL TO I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. DR TONYA TAIWO. AN
EPIDEMIOLOGIST FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS.
FOLLOWED BY POLY MARSHALL A
BREAST CANCER SURVIVOR. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN WOULD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY ON BEHALF OF EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY FIVE. AS USED AS THE
RESIDENTS SAID MY NAME IS
DOCTOR T<c.cyan> WILL I'M AN</c>
EPIDEMIOLOGIST ND CO DIRECTOR
OF THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
COURT THE UC DAVIS
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH SCIENCES
CENTER. I'M ALSO A MIDWIFE AT
COMMUNICATOR HEALTH SET HEALTH
CENTERS IN YOLO COUNTY MY
RESEARCH FOCUSES ON THE EFFECT
OF PRENATAL ENVIRONMENTAL
EXPOSURES ON CHILD DEVELOPMENT.
AB FOR NINETY FIVE IS A COMMON
SENSE BILL. THAT WOULD BAN
ELEVEN OF THE MOST TOXIC
CHEMICALS FROM COSMETIC
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA THESE
ARE CHEMICALS WHERE THE SCIENCE
IS UNDISPUTED AS TO THE HARM
THAT CAUSED INCLUDING CANCER
BIRTH DEFECTS. DAMAGE TO THE
REPRODUCTIVE SYSTEM AND HARM TO
THE DEVELOPING BRAIN IN YOUNG
CHILDREN IF I CAN JUST SPEAK TO
A COUPLE OF THOSE CHEMICALS.
MERCURY IS TOXIC TO THE
DEVELOPING BRAIN AND KIDNEYS.
PHTHALATES AND PARABENS ARE TWO
CLASSES OF HORMONE DISRUPTING
INDUSTRIAL CHEMICALS UBIQUITOUS
AND BEAUTY PRODUCTS VIRTUALLY
ALL AMERICANS HAVE VALLEY'S AND
PARABEN BUT HAVE LIGHTS AND
THEIR BODIES. WOMEN OF
CHILDBEARING AGE ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE AS THEY
ARE THE PRIMARY CONSUMERS OF
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS WOMEN OF
COLOR HAVE HIGHER LEVELS OF
PRODUCT RELATED CHEMICALS IN
THEIR BODIES BECAUSE THEY USE
MORE TYPES OF PRODUCTS AND THE
ONES MARKETED TO THEM. ARE
OFTEN OFTEN CONTAIN MORE TOXIC
CHEMICALS. BLACK WOMEN IN
PARTICULAR SPEND MORE THAN FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS ON BEAUTY
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES TWICE AS
MUCH AS ANY OTHER AND THROUGH.
WORK IS IN THE BEAUTY INDUSTRY
ARE OFTEN REPRODUCTIVE AGE
WOMEN FROM UNDER REPRESENTATIVE
GROUPS AND THEY MAY BE MORE
VULNERABLE TO THE ADVERSE
HEALTH EFECTS BECAUSE THEY
HANDLE THESE CHEMICALS ALL DAY
LONG. THEY ALSO MAYBE FACING
HIGHER CUMULATIVE EXPOSURES
FROM MULTIPLE SOURCES IN THE
HOME NEIGHBORHOOD AND WORKPLACE.
THE COSMETIC INDUSTRY ARGUES
THAT A LITTLE BIT OF A
CARCINOGENIC CHEMICAL IN A
CONSUMER PRODUCT ISN'T A COURT
CAUSE FOR CONCERN BUT THIS IS
SIMPLY NOT TRUE. SCIENCE TELLS
US THAT FOR HORMONALLY. ACTIVE
CHEMICALS EVEN SMALL EXPOSURES
CAN CAUSE HARM FOR DEVELOPING
FETUSES EXPOSURE TO EVEN SMALL
AMOUNTS OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
DURING IMPORTANT TIMES OF
DEVELOPMENT CAN HAVE
IRREVERSIBLE IMPACT. AND PLACE
THE CHILD ON THE PATH FOR LATER
LIKE DISEASE AND THESE PROBLEMS
CAN PERSIST ACROSS GENERATIONS.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT THE BREAST
CANCER. BLACK WOMEN WHO AND IT
RECENT AND I. H. STUDY SHOWED
THAT BLACK WOMEN WHO FREQUENTLY
DYE THEIR HAIR FACE A 60%
INCREASE RISK OF BREAST CANCER
WHICH IS A SPECIALLY APPALLING
BECAUSE BLACK WOMEN ALREADY
FACE THE HIGHEST MORTALITY
RATE. FROM BREAST CANCER OF ANY
U. S. RACIAL GROUP. THE N. I.
H. STUDY ALSO IMPLICATED HAIR
STRAIGHTENERS AS A SCIENTIST. A
MOTHER AND A BLACK WOMAN FACING
THE STATISTICAL PROBABILITY.
THAT MY RISK OF BREAST CANCER
AND MY DAUGHTERS WOULD BE
INCREASED SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS THAT WE BUY. I'M HERE
TO TELL YOU THAT'S NOT OKAY.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
PAULA MARSHALL AND I'M A BREAST
CANCER SURVIVOR. AFTER MY
DIAGNOSIS AT AGE FIFTY TWO I
HAD THREE SURGERIES THREE
MONTHS OF CHEMOTHERAPY AND FIVE
WEEKS OF DAILY RADIATION
TREATMENTS. I'M HERE TODAY TO
TELL YOU WHY AB FOR NINETY FIVE
IS SO IMPORTANT TO ME AND
BREAST CANCER SURVIVORS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. ONE OUT
OF EVERY EIGHT WOMEN IN THE U.
S. IS DIET WILL BE DIAGNOSED
WITH BREAST CANCER IN HER
LIFETIME. AND FIFTY THOUSAND
WOMEN WILL DIE FROM THE DISEASE
EVERY YEAR IN THE UNITED STATES
ALONE. TEN OUT OF THAT NOW
ELEVEN CHEMICALS THAT WOULD BE
BANNED BY A. B. FOR NINETY FIVE
FROM BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE DIRECTLY LINKED TO BREAST
CANCER TEN OUT OF THE ELEVEN.
THIS IS NOT SORRY PASSING A
BEFORE NINETY FIVE WILL REMOVE
ONE MAJOR SOURCE OF WOMEN'S
ONGOING EXPOSURE TO SOME OF THE
MOST TOXIC SUBSTANCES ON EARTH.
THIS IS NOT A HYPOTHETICAL
ISSUE WOMEN LIKE ME LIVING WITH
BREAST CANCER. LIVE IN DAILY
FEAR OF REOCCURRENCE OF THIS
DEVASTATING DISEASE AND WE FEAR
FOR OUR CHILDREN WHO ARE
CONSIDERED AT HIGH RISK OF
BREAST CANCER SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY ARE OUR CHILDREN.
COMPANIES SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
TO CONTINUE TO USE CHEMICALS
WITH KNOWN LINKS TO BREAST
CANCER IN BEAUTY AND PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN THEY'RE USING
THE WHEN THEY ARE SELLING THE
EXACT SAME PRODUCTS IN THE E.
U. WITHOUT THESE CANCER CAUSING
CHEMICALS. AB FOR NINETY FIVE
WOULD PUT AN END TO THIS DOUBLE
STANDARD. PLEASE PROTECT ME AND
OTHER BREAST CANCER SURVIVORS.
PLEASE PROTECT OUR CHILDREN.
PLEASE VOTE YES TO PASS THIS
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN A WE
ARE ALSO JOINED BY- THE JOINT
AUTHOR OF A BEFORE NINETY FIVE
SOMETHING OR WICKS. CHECK.
THIRTY LENDING MY VOICE. THANK
YOU YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS EMILY RASH AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HOW
PARK OR ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS
OF THE SPELL- ALL ALSO LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FROM BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS THE LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS AND THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME'S LARA THE HAND-I'M ALSO WITH CALPERS I WANTED
TO REGISTER SUPPORT TODAY ON
BEHALF OF ALASKA COMMUNITY
ACTION ON TOXICS. BREAST CANCER
ACTION. BREAST CANCER OVER
TIME. AND THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
COALITION ADVOCACY GROUP THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS MATT THE
TIES AND I'M THE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR OF BREAST CANCER OVER
TIME I'D LIKE ALSO LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FROM EAGLE
PLAN EIGHTY TWO DEGREES DESIGN
STUDIO EO PRODUCTS HAN SCARE.
HON SKIN CARE COSMETICS INNER
SENSE ORGANIC BEAUTY JUST THE
GOODS AND SO YEAH. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JANET NOODLE MAN AND
I'M HERE TO REGISTER SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS WERE ONE OF
THE BILL'S SPONSORS AND ALSO
1100% PURE. BADGER BALM
BELIEVES THE ORGANIC A
CALIFORNIA BABY CREDO BEAUTY
AND EARTH MAMA ORGANICS THANK
YOU. PERSONAL GET US HERE WE
HAVE A CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND
NATIONAL STARSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. OKAY RIGHT
SPENCER MERTON COLLEGE OBGYN
STRYCHNINE IN SUPPORT. JANUARY
TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. JIM WHEN
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION TO
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LAUREN COLUMN WAS SIERRA CLUB
HELLO MY NAME IS LISA VAN FLEET
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF SIX A
CLEAN BEAUTY COMPANIES THAT
WORK WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR SAFE
COSMETICS WHICH WHO SUPPORT
THIS BILL ALSO NATURAL SEVENTH
GENERATION SKIN EL SPROUT SAN
FRANCISCO SERENA BOOK
SUSTAINABLE. SURROUNDINGS AND
THE HOLISTIC HEALTH COMPANY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HELLO I'M
CAROLE CRONIN WHETHER I'M A
LICENSED CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST
IN A MINUTE ADVOCATES OF BREAST
CANCER SURVIVOR AND MEMBER OF
BREAST CANCER OVER TIME. WE
STRONGLY I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS. MEASURE I HAVE WORKED IN
YEARS THIRTY FIVE YEARS IN THIS
FIELD AND SEEN TOO MANY YOUNG
WOMEN COME THROUGH. AND OLDER
WOMEN OF COURSE WE NEED TO STOP.
POISONING OURSELVES THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE. THAT THE MYSELF THIS IS A
LITTLE I. I'M WITHIN THE SEASON
SEASON LITTLE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
WE ARE ALSO ONE OF THE SPONSORS
AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION
. SO CHAIR MEMBERS
IMMEDIATELY ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL
THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY JOB- TESTIFYING N
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL I WANNA
START OFF BY- GOING THROUGH THE
REASONS THAT WE DO OPPOSE A
BILL AND WHY WE DON'T OPPOSE A
BILL I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO LEVEL SET- WE DO
NOT OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE
ANY OF OUR MEMBER COMPANIES
INTENTIONALLY ADD. ANY OF THESE
ELEVEN THIRTEEN I'M SORRY
INGREDIENTS INTO OUR PRODUCTS
WE OPPOSE FUNDAMENTALLY BECAUSE
THE LEGISLATURE DICTATING
CHEMICAL POLICY WHEN WE ALREADY
HAVE GREEN CHEMISTRY IN PLACE
WHICH IS A PROGRAM THAT
COMPREHENSIVELY AND
SCIENTIFICALLY LOOKS AT
CHEMICALS AND CHEMICAL BANDS
AND THEY LOOK AT ALTERNATIVES-
IS A BETTER PROCESS IN FACT
THERE WAS A BILL SPONSORED BY.
SENATOR ALLEN THAT WOULD HAVE
EXPEDITED THAT PROGRAM WE WENT
NEUTRAL WE ARE FULLY BEHIND
MAKING A PROGRAM THAT WORKS THE
LEADING TO IDENTIFYING
CHEMICALS OF CONCERN IN
IDENTIFYING ALTERNATIVES TO
THEM WORK BETTER AND I WANT TO
SAY THAT FOR THE RECORD- WE
TESTIFIED IN THE PREVIOUS
POLICY COMMITTEE AND E. S. T.
M. AND STATED OUR REASONS FOR
OPPOSING A BEFORE NINETY FIVE
LARGELY STEM FROM. THE LACK OF
ALIGNMENT THAT THIS BILL HAS
WITH THE E. U. COSMETIC
REGULATIONS- YOU'LL JUST
RECEIVE THESE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE JUST RECEIVED ABOUT AN HOUR
AGO FROM THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND- I HAVE TO SAY THAT I'M
QUITE DISAPPOINTED IN THE
PROCESS THAT IS TAKING PLACE
OVER THE LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS
NAMELY THAT. WE WALKED OUT OF
THE STM COMMITTEE THREE DAYS
AGO FEELING VERY GOOD ABOUT THE
COMMITMENTS THAT WERE MADE AND
JUST LESS THAN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AGO WE HEARD FROM SEVERAL
SOURCES NOT JUST ONE SEVERAL
SOURCES THAT THEY DID NOT
INTEND. ON COMMITTING FULLY TO
THE AGREEMENT THAT WAS MADE IN
THE STM COMMITTEE. AND AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE. AS PART OF THE
INTEGRITY OF THE LEGISLATIVE
NEGOTIATION PROCESS- WE WERE
VERY DISAPPOINTED IT. IN
LEARNING THAT AND. AND STARTED
TALKING TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ABOUT LAYING OFF THE BILL AS A
RESULT OF THAT BREACH OF THAT
THAT AGREEMENT. WE RECEIVE
THESE AMENDMENTS ABOUT AN HOUR
AGO AND WE ARE FEVERISHLY
HAVING OUR COMPANIES AND OUR
LEGAL TEAMS LOOK AT THEM AND I
HAVE TO ADMIT THAT THIS IS
PROGRESS ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT THE AUTHOR AGREE TO ANY
SEM COMMITTEE HOWEVER. THERE IS
ONE SECTION THAT WE ARE STILL
NOT SURE GETS IS TOO FULL
ALIGNMENT WITH THE E. U. FULL
ALIGNMENT WITH THE E. U. AS
WHAT WE WERE PROMISED. ANY
ANYTHING THAT CAN BE SOLD IN
THE TWENTY EIGHT STATES IN THE
E. U. THE AUTHOR AND THE CHAIR
OF THE SEM COMMITTEE PROMISED
US COULD BE SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE NEED TO BE ABSOLUTELY
CERTAIN. IN PRINT IN BLACK AND
WHITE. THAT THIS BILL GETS US
FULLY ALIGNED WITH THE E. U. WE
ARE NOT CERTAIN THAT
SUBDIVISION BEAT DOES THAT. IN
PART BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WE
CALL THE TRACE EXCEPTIONS.
WHERE CONTAMINANTS I HAVE TIME.
ALL A WRAP UP RIGHT NOW WE'RE
NOT SURE THAT SUBDIVISION BE
GETS US THERE- WE CONTINUE TO
COMMIT OURSELVES TO ALIGN
OURSELVES FULLY WITH THE E. YOU
SHOULD THE AUTHOR INTRODUCE A
NEW BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE OUT OF WRIGLEY ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AS IN- IN PRINT WE
HAVEN'T REALLY HAD TIME TO
REVIEW THE LANGUAGE RECEIVED AN
HOUR AGO REGARDING THE INTENT
LANGUAGE WE HAVE HEARD FROM THE
AUTHOR YOU'RE COMMITTED TO
ALIGN ITH THE E. U. WE
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT- THAT
COMMITMENT AND WILL LOOK FOR
TO. CONTINUE ENGAGEMENT THANKS.
THE COOKING YOURS ON BEHALF OF
THE FRAGRANCE CREATORS
ASSOCIATION- ECHO THE COMMENTS
BEFORE ON JUST OUT APPRECIATE
THE PROGRESS SO FAR BUT YES WE
DO STILL NEED TO REVIEW. THANK
YOU. CHAIRMAN PERCENT JUST LIKE
WITH AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL- ALIGN MYSELF A COMMA
SO THE CHAMBER AND NOT MISS CAN
KNOWN AS- APPRECIATE THE WORK
SO FAR THE AUTHOR IN THE AND
SPONSORS. THANK YOU. Q. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DON
CAP KHIMIK YOU CAP CAN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION. I SEEM
TO DOES APPRECIATE THE GREAT
PROGRESS THAT'S BEEN MADE A WE
TOO. ARE WORKING WITH OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES TO REVIEW
OTHER PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WE
RECEIVED I JUST THIS MORNING-
ABBOTT DO BELIEVE IT TIED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND HOPE TO
BE. ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
INFORMATION VERY QUICKLY THANK
YOU. YOU ANYONE ELSE. NOT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THIS
CARILLO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION ON COMMITMENTS
THAT YOU MADE IN THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE AND HOW THOSE
COMMITMENTS ARE NOW IMPLEMENTED
IN YOUR NEW AMENDMENTS YES
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO. YOU
KNOW. I COMMITTED IN THE
ENVIRONMENT SAFETY COMMITTEE
THAT. WE WOULD WORK TO ALIGN.
THE STANDARDS IN THIS BILL TO
THE STANDARDS OF THE EUROPEAN
UNION. I BELIEVE. WE HAVE- THE
BILL AND THAT MIRRORS THE
STANDARDS OF THE ENVIRONMENT OF
A EUROPEAN UNION AT THIS POINT.
AND IN FACT I WAS LOOKING FOR.
THE REPRESENTED FROM THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL.
TO IDENTIFY ANY SPECIFIC
PROVISION THAT DOES NOT MAYOR
THE- EUROPEAN UNION STANDARDS
NOW FAIR ENOUGH- THESE
AMENDMENTS WE SCRAMBLED TO GET
THEM OUT. LATE YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON. AND. INTO LAST NIGHT
BECAUSE OF MY CONVERSATIONS
WITH SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LATE YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON INDICATING TO ME THAT
THEY DID NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE
AND VOTING ON A BILL WITHOUT
THIS SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THEY
WANTED KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'RE GONNA BE VOTING ON.
FAIR ENOUGH WE SCRAMBLED IN AND
GOT THAT LANGUAGE SO. YOU KNOW
I FEEL. IN ALL MY HEART THAT I
HAVE MET MY COMMITMENTS AND I
TAKE ANY CHALLENGES TO MY
INTEGRITY SERIOUSLY I BELIEVE
IN ALL MY HEART THAT THIS. IS
SOMETHING THAT IS ENTIRELY
CONSISTENT WITH MY COMMITMENT
TO PRESENT A BILL THAT MIRRORS
THE STANDARDS OF THE EUROPEAN
UNION AND IF THERE ARE ANY
SPECIFIC PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL THAT DOES NOT. NEAR THE
STANDARDS OF THE EUROPEAN UNION
I ASK RIGHT NOW. YOU KNOW WHERE
TO IDENTIFY THOSE MS. KIM. THE
ANSWER. MS LEE IDENTIFIED
SUBDIVISION BE. OF THE DRAFT
LANGUAGE THAT YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU. AND THIS LANGUAGE IS IT
ENTIRELY IN WELL IT BUT LET ME
NOW TURN IT OFF IF I MAY MISTER
CHAIR TO THIS IS A LITTLE WITH
ENVIRONMENT WORKING GROUP WHO.
WORKED ON THIS LANGUAGE. THANK
YOU I WOULD JUST LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT THE LAND AND LANGUAGE
IDENTIFIED IN SUBDIVISION AND-
THEN- SUBDIVISION BE BE THERE
IS ACTUALLY LANGUAGE THAT WAS
DRAFTED BY THE STM COMMITTEES
STAFF AND WAS PROPOSED IN THE
STM COMMITTEE. ANALYSIS AND
THAT IS WHAT'S ADOPTED THE
CHANGES THERE ARE TWO TO
CONFORM WITH THE AMENDMENTS
EVERY MOVING- PARAGRAPHS ONE
AND TWO WHICH INCLUDE AS BEST
US AND LEAD FROM THE BILL.
THOSE ARE THE ONLY CHANGES WE
HAVE MADE TO THAT LANGUAGE THAT
THE COMMITTEE DRAFTED. AND SO
WE DO BELIEVE AND WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO MAINTAIN THAT
THESE AMENDMENTS CONFORM- WITH
THE E. U. STANDARD WE STRIPPED
EVERYTHING OUT OF THE BILL.
THAT COULD- BE PERCEIVED AS NOT
CONFORMING WITH THAT STANDARD.
AT THIS TIME AND WE- AGAIN TO
REITERATE THE AUTHORS
STATEMENTS WE ARE COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT THAT IS WHAT WE
PERCEIVE WE CONFORM WITH MOVING
FORWARD. THROUGH THE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS THANK YOU. AND IF
I MAY MISTER CHAIR AND FURTHER
ANSWERING A MYSTERY AS QUESTION.
YOU KNOW. IT GIVES US NO
PLEASURE TO TAKE OUT THE
PROTECTIONS FOR. COSMETICS
THAT- CONTAIN LEAD AND ASBESTOS
YOU KNOW THOSE. ACCORDING TO
MISTER MCCARTY AND SOME OTHERS
THAT I SPOKE WITH IN- ON THE
COMMITTEE ARE ARGUABLY THE
BIGGEST CONCERNS IN TERMS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. BUT WE MADE THE
HARD DECISION TO TAKE OUT
PERHAPS THE TWO MOST IMPORTANT
CHEMICALS IN ORDER TO
DEMONSTRATE OUR GOOD FAITH TO
COMPLY WITH THE COMMITMENT THAT
WE MADE TO MIRROR THE E. U.'S
STANDARDS. THERE IS AMBIGUITY
AS TO THE E. U. STANDARDS AS IT
RELATES TO ASBESTOS AND LEAD
FOR EXAMPLE A SPOUSE'S- THERE
ARE DIFFERENT STANDARDS THEY'RE
DIFFERENT FORSMAN STANDARDS
DEPENDING ON THE MEMBER
COUNTRIES OF THE EUROPEAN
UNION. AND WE COULD NOT COME UP
WITH THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE TO
MEET- YOU NOTED THAT DEFINE ONE
STANDARD FOR AS BASSES AND SAID
THAT IS THE REASON WHY WE TOOK
IT OUT. THAT BUT I WANT TO MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT THAT IS. YOU KNOW
FURTHER EMONSTRATION THAT'S
ABOUT AS GOOD AS DEMONSTRATION
AS AS I CAN GIVE OF OUR GOOD
FAITH COMMITMENT TO. MEET THE
STANDARDS OUTLINED THIS BILL
WITH THE STANDARDS OF THE
EUROPEAN UNION BY TAKING OUT TO
A PERHAPS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
CHEMICALS THAT WE ARE SEAT
ORIGINALLY SEEKING TO ADDRESS.
OTHER OTHER QUESTIONS COMES.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ. YEAH I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THIS AS
WELL BECAUSE OVERSEE THAT THE
LANGUAGE IS FAIRLY NEW WE
HAVEN'T EVEN AT TWENTY FOUR
HOURS TO REALLY GO IN AND LOOK
AND DETAIL BUT THE COMMITTEE
PRIOR WAS A TUESDAY OR
WEDNESDAY TUESDAY TO THURSDAY
SO I THINK WHAT WAS CAUSING ALL
THE PROBLEMS IS BECAUSE
EVERYTHING WAS LIKE YOU SAID
SCRAMBLED LATE LAST NIGHT TO
MAKE SOME CHANGES BECAUSE THERE
WERE SOME ISSUES WITH THE BILL-
I THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
IN THE SOONER I THINK. THAT WE
WOULD HAVE AT LEAST TWENTY FOUR
HOURS TO REALLY FULLY THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN. THE TENT I WAS
ROOTING FOR SO I THINK THAT'S
PART OF THE PROBLEM AS WELL. I
KIND OF FEEL THAT IF YOU'RE
SHOULD HAVE. BEEN REALLY
COMMITTED AFTER THAT COMMITTEE
HEARING TO. START RODERICK
GREEN THAT LANGUAGE THAT WE
WOULD HAVE A DAY OR TWO RIGHT.
NOW WE'RE LIKE UP AGAINST THE
WALL. SO I'M STILL TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND AS WELL SOME. AYE
PREACHER YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IT
AND I KNOW YOU'VE- DONE A LOT
OF SIGNIFICANT CHANGES I THINK.
BECAUSE IT'S SO NEW WE ONLY
HAVE OURS BASICALLY TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND EVERYTHING- THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I KNOW
YOU'RE WORKING ON THIS BILL.
AND YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH THE
GOAL OF THE BILL. AND I. AGREE
THAT WE SHOULD BE EXPOSED TO
CHEMICALS OR PRODUCTS THE LOWER
SAFETY STANDARDS- THAN THOSE OF
THE E. U. I'M FRUSTRATED FOR
YOU BECAUSE I WISH THIS WOULD
HAVE COME QUICKER AND WE'RE
SCRAMBLING AS YOU CAN SEE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
LANGUAGE MEANS AND TRYING TO
TALK TO EVERYONE UP HERE ON THE
COUNT. ON THE DíAS. BUT YOU IN
YOUR SPONSORS OF EXPRESS THAT
IT'S DIFFICULT TO WRITE PARITY
LANGUAGE ON THIS ONE- I'LL BE
THE FIRST TO HELP YOU. LATER ON
NO ONE I THINK WE SHOULD WE
LOOK THIS- AND AT THIS POINT
I'M GOING TO STAFF THE BILL
TODAY IF IT COMES BACK TO THE
FLOOR PASSES COMMITTEE. I'M
HOPEFULLY THE CHANGES THAT WE
CAN REALLY SPEND SOME TIME ON
IT BUT THIS IS COME SO QUICKLY-
AND YOU DID A GREAT JOB YOU GOT
THIS TO ME THIS MORNING I ASKED
YOU. NO LATER THAN THIS
MORNING- BUT I'M FINDING THAT
THERE'S- SOME DISCREPANCIES AND
SOME OTHER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
THAT. I NEED TO DATE WITH MY
STAFF AS WELL SO WITHOUT
APPEALING OFFICE TODAY.
ACTUALLY IT WAS THE MAN FOR
SOME SORRY MY BAD. THANK YOU-
AND I ACTUALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
KNOW THAT LAST YEAR THERE WERE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS AND AT
THE TIME THE COMMITTEE DIDN'T
YOU KNOW OR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ALSO DIDN'T FEEL PREPARED- AND
TO VOTE ON A AND THE BILL HAS
CHANGED TO SOME EXTENT. I THINK
YOU KNOW FOR ME IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT CONSUMERS HAVE TRUST IN
ALL PRODUCTS I DID I KNOW AND
YOU KNOW I DID SOME WORK
RELATED TO LEAD- PREVENTION-
AND PRIOR TO GETTING TO THE
ASSEMBLY AND IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF LEADS-
FOCUS BILLS. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MOVE FORWARD IN IN
TERMS OF HEALTH AND SAFETY SO
ALL TO SAY THAT THE PRODUCTS
THAT ARE OUT THERE WHETHER IT'S
IN PAINTING IN MAKE UP IN A
HOME ANYTHING THEY THEY HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE ON THE HEALTH OF
A HUMAN- AND I THINK THAT. IT'S
SO IT'S GREAT TO HEAR THAT TH
PRODUCTS ARE ARE NOT USING THAT
THAT THE THAN THOSE
MANUFACTURING PRODUCTS ARE
COMMITTED TO NOT HAVING THOSE
PRODUCTS. ON IN. DOES ELEMENT
IN THE PRODUCTS- AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT IT SOUNDS
NOW THAT THIS IS- A MATTER OF
PROCESS IT'S A MATTER. OF WHAT
WE CAN YOU KNOW DO TO CLARIFY.
THIS PARTICULAR LANGUAGE THAT'S
BEING I THINK THAT MEMBERS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT. BUT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS- AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE IT'S AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION AND I
THINK THAT THIS IS SOMETHING-
IT'S IN THE EARLY. SPACES THERE
IS STILL MULTIPLE COMMITTEES
THAT THIS THE BILL HAS TO GO TO
SO I THINK THAT WHAT'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS A PROBLEM. HAS A
PATHWAY FOR A SOLUTION- AND I
THINK THAT IN THE END- I WANT
THE- CONSUMER TO FEEL THAT THEY
CAN TRUST. THE PRODUCTS THAT
THEY USE- AND THAT'S IN MAKE UP
AND ANYTHING ELSE AND SO- I
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT. I KNOW
THAT TO AND THERE'S YOU KNOW
LOTS OF DISCUSSION ABOUT. THE
PROCESS ITSELF BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
IF. AS THIS MOVES FORWARD- THAT
THERE COULD ALSO BE A WAY TO
ADD. A LINE- SOME OF THE
CONCERNS I IT IN A WAY THAT'S-
POSITIVE TOWARDS THE BILL SO
THANK YOU. THE CHRISTMAS BURKE.
I'LL BE QUICK I WANNA LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC I KNOW IT
IS VERY VERY DIFFICULT I KNOW
IT'S VERY VERY COMPLEX RIGHT
FOR ME I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THE ISSUE
AS- HOWEVER IT HOWEVER YOU DO
THAT AND CLARIFYING SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT.
UNCLEAR HOWEVER I HAVE NOT HAD
THE TIME AND NIGHT WE HAVE BEEN
RUNNING IN AND OUT TRYING TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN UNDERSTAND
WITH COMMITTEE STAFF AND OUR
OWN STAFF BUT I DON'T THINK I
HAVE MY- ARMS WRAPPED AROUND
THIS WELL ENOUGH YET SO FOR ME
I'M GONNA LAY OFF RIGHT NOW BUT
IF IT. COMES DOWN TO THE FLOOR
I LOOK FOR TO HOPEFULLY IT
BEING CLEANED UP TO A PLACE
WHERE WE CAN ALL SPORTING. MR
MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I WANT TO TALK A BIT ABOUT THE-
THE POLICY BUT ALSO THE PROCESS
SO YOU KNOW I WASN'T ON ESPN
COMEDIAN MEASURE ANYBODY ELSE
HE WAS BUT MY UNDERSTANDING AND
I FEEL LIKE WALKING INTO THIS
MOVIE WHEN IT'S HALFWAY. IS
THAT THERE WAS A COMMITMENT TO
HAVE YOU WORK ON- SENSE ENERGY
WITH THE LANGUAGE FOR THE E. U.
AND YOU'RE GONNA DO THAT
THROUGH THE APPROPRIATIONS.
PROCESS DOWN THE ROAD NOT
NECESSARILY BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE. AND SO THE REASON
THAT YOU RUSHED TO DO THESE
NAMES TODAY IS BECAUSE THERE
WAS. BASICALLY NOT COVER THAT
IT WAS. THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE BUT WHAT WHAT
I'M I'M CONFUSED WHAT DID YOU
ACTUALLY COMMIT TO DOING AND
WHAT WAS THE TIME PERIOD WAS IT
YOU'RE GONNA TRY TO. APPS
LANGUAGE ON THIS PIECE BEFORE
TODAY'S HEARING. YES SO THANK
YOU MISTER MCCARTY SO- IN THE
ENVIRONMENT SAFETY COMMITTEE ON
TUESDAY. I WAS ABLE TO GET
COURTESY VOTES FROM MY
COLLEAGUES TO MOVE THE BILL
FORD FOR THE SAKE OF- HAVING
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION ON
THIS IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION ON THE COMMITMENT
THAT WE A LINE- THE STANDARDS
IN THIS BILL WITH THE EUROPEAN
UNION. WE WERE ORIGINALLY
HOPING TO. BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
THE CONTINUE THE WORK WITH THE
S. HIM STAFF- AS WELL AS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE STAFF
TO COME UP WITH LANGUAGE- IT
TOO BUT. SPECIFICALLY DEFINE
THE EUROPEAN THE APPLICA
EUROPEAN STANDARDS IN ORDER TO
MEET OUR COMMITMENT TO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE EUROPEAN-
THE STANDARDS. HOWEVER WHEN I
STARTED HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SAYING THAT WHAT WE DON'T WANT
YOU KNOW JUST A COMMITMENT WE
WANT TO SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THAT-
PROMPTED US- AND RECORD AS TO.
TO HAVE TO SCRAMBLE TO MAKE
SOME HARD DECISIONS AND- SO
WHAT WE DID WHAT WE DID DECIDE
AND WHAT IS BEFORE YOU RIGHT
NOW. IS YOU KNOW THE OF THE
REMAINING CHEMICALS THOSE
CHEMICALS- ARE. BANNED IN THE
U. E. U. AND OUR BILL IS
ENTIRELY ALIGNED WITH THE E. U.
BUT BECAUSE THERE ARE
COMPLEXITIES WITH THE E. U.
STANDARDS AS AS TO LEAD IN THIS
BEST THIS. IN ORDER TO MEET OUR
COMMITMENT THAT'S WHY WE
ENTIRELY TOOK THOSE TWO
CHEMICALS OUT OF THE BILL. SO
THAT- IT DOES THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION IN TERMS OF THE YEAH I
THINK IT IT IT PUTS YOU IN A
VERY DIFFICULT POSITION BECAUSE
THERE'S JUST THREE DAYS AGO.
AND YOU YOU DIDN'T NECESSARILY
HAVE THE CAME TO DO IT BEFORE
TODAY BUT WORKING WITH THE
PARTIES BEFORE AS WE MOVE ALONG
OTHERS SAY THAT YOU WANTED TO
GET THE BOOKS TODAY SO YOU TRY
TO. RUSH IN THERE AND THAT'S
WHY IT SEEMS THAT THERE'S NOT
TIME. TO LOOK AT THAT SO I HAVE
ANOTHER OPINION ON THAT BUT
THAT'S OKAY AS FAR AS THE
MERITS OF THIS- YOU KNOW
OVERALL WHEN YOU INTEREST AS A
YEAR AGO I THOUGHT OF THAT RISK%
REWARD IS THERE MORE REWARD TO.
CONSUMERS AND ESPECIALLY YOUNG
PEOPLE WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT A
SECOND. OR MORE RESTED THIS
INDUSTRY THAT I WOULD CRATER
AND- YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS
STEPPED UP ABOVE. THE FDA AND
OTHER ISSUES AND SO I THINK
THIS IS ONE WHERE CALIFORNIA
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD AND
IT WAS ESPECIALLY. DISTURBING
LIKE YOU MENTIONED TO SEEING
THE IMPACT OF SOME OF THESE
PRODUCTS. ON KIDS I HAVE TWEENS
JUST LIKE YOU. AND THEY'RE YOU
KNOW DYING TO GO THE NEXT STEP
BEYOND SPEAKING. LIP GLOSS HERE
AND THERE. AND THE THAT THAT'S
THE BEST DOSE AND LET IN THOSE
PRODUCTS IS VERY DISTURBING.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW WE CAN SAY
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO STEP UP
THIS CALIFORNIA TO FURTHER-
PROTECT OUR CONSUMERS AND OUR
KIDS IN. AN INDUSTRY THAT YOU
KNOW I THINK HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND JUST TRYING NOT TO
INCLUDE THESE DANGERS ELEMENTS.
IN COSMETIC PRODUCTS. AND THE
THING THAT WE HEARD ABOUT FROM
THAT ARE THE TWO ELEMENTS THAT
YOU TOOK OUT RIGHT. BEST US AND
LET. SO HOW. AND IT MAY NAY BE
STRONG ENOUGH IN THE FIRST
PLACE TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
SO. HOW WOULD HOW WOULD YOU.
AGAIN SELL US THAT. YOU'RE
BEING- RESPONSIVE TO. ADMIT
THAT TO AT HEARING TO THE EASE
STANDARDS WITH THOSE TWO
PIECES. THE STATUS OF THAT. AND
THAT- THE OVERALL. IT TO
INCREASE THE SPEED OF YOUR
TRYING TO ACHIEVE GOING FOR. SO
AGAIN WE TOOK OUT. THE SPACES
AND LEAD BECAUSE THOSE WITH IT
THE TWO AND THE ONLY TWO
CHEMICALS THAT WE HEARD- FROM
IS LEE THAT WERE. RAISING
CONCERNS WITH FEAR OPPOSITION
IN TERMS OF- DEFINING AND
ALIGNING WITH THE EUROPEAN
UNION STANDARDS. BUT BECAUSE OF
THE COMPLEXITIES IN DEFINING
THE EUROPEAN STANDARDS- ASKED
TO ONLY THOSE TWO CHEMICALS.
YOU KNOW RATHER THAN. TRYING
TO- TO COME UP OF LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD ADDRESS THE COMPLEX
COMPLICATED EUROPEAN UNION
STANDARDS- WE AT MEAN IN ORDER
TO. ATTEMPT TO MOVE THE BILL
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE WE
DECIDED TO DROP THOSE THOSE TWO
CHEMICALS ENTIRELY AS TO THE
REMAINING ELEVEN CHEMICALS WE
HAVE NOT HEARD ANY CONCERNS. UP
UNTIL NOW- AS TO THOSE ELEVEN
CHEMICALS I BELIEVE THAT THOSE
ELEVEN CHEMICALS ARE ENTIRELY
ALIGNED WITH THE EUROPEAN UNION
STANDARDS MS LEE INDICATED AND
MY MEETING WITH HER THAT THAT-
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR A GLOBAL
STANDARD. SO THAT WHAT IS SOLD
IN EUROPE CAN BE SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS CAN ENJOY
THE SAME- MY PERSPECTIVES LIKE
A CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS CAN
ENJOY THE SAME PER. CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AS THOSE A READY
BEING ENJOYED IN THE IN THE
EUROPEAN UNION. SO EVEN AS YOUR
AIM LAW HOW WOULD YOU PROTECT
CONSUMERS AGAINST. EXPOSURE AND
PRODUCTS FROM LEAD IN THIS BEST.
SO THERE ARE CURRENT LAWS
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS THAT-
THAT TO- YOU KNOW ATTEMPT TO
REGULATE TOXIC CHEMICALS AND
COSMETICS BUT YOU KNOW AS WE'VE
SEEN AS A FROM THE RECENT
EXAMPLES OF PRODUCTS BEING SOLD
TO CALIFORNIA ANOTHER CONSUMERS
IN THE COUNTRY THOSE LAWS YOU
KNOW OUR- ARE ARE ARE BEING
INADEQUATELY ENFORCED.
FUNDAMENTALLY WHERE WHERE WE'RE
DEALING WITH THE SITUATION
WHERE THE FTA AND- THE
DEPARTMENT THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH LACKS GROSSLY
LACKS THE NECESSARY RESOURCES
TO- ADEQUATELY PROTECT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS- MISLEAD.
ARE MENTIONED THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM THE CHAIR OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
COMMITTEE AND ONE OF HIS MORE
MEMORABLE LINES- STATED THAT-
IN IN TERMS OF THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY PROGRAM. THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL IS IN HIS WORDS
CONSTIPATED. YOU KNOW THEY THEY
THEY THEY THEY HAVE ONLY
SUCCEEDED AND- REGULATING-
CHEMICALS THREE CHEMICAL
COMBINATIONS AND THEIR ELEVEN
YEARS OF EXISTENCE IN THE
MEANTIME WE ARE SEEING A SPAZ
TO THIS- MERCURY AND FACIAL
CREAMS FORMALDEHYDE AND HAIR
STRAIGHTENERS ME CLEARLY THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING
SO IT IN ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTION IN MISTER MCCARTY WE
DO HAVE LAWS- THAT THAT ATTEMPT
TO. TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS BUT AS WE'VE SEEN-
WITH THE DISCOVERY OF TOXIC
CHEMICALS- BEING SOLD TO
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS CURRENT
LAWS ARE INADEQUATE AND THAT'S
WHY EIGHTY FOUR NINETY FIVE. IS
NECESSARY. THANK YOU MISTER FOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- SO RUN
JUST CURIOUS SO CLEARLY THERE'S
AN APPETITE TO VOTE ON
SOMETHING LIKE THIS I CLEARLY
INDUSTRY IS READY AND WILLING
TO NEGOTIATE ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES SO WHY THE RUSH BY WIRE
WE RUN THIS THROUGH AT AT THE
ELEVENTH HOUR CLEARLY THERE IS
A PATH WHEN THERE'S TIME SO I'M
JUST CURIOUS WHY THE RUSH. OKAY
WELL. I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION- I MISSED FLORA YOU
KNOW FIRST OF ALL THIS AND I
WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE THIS IS
A TO YOUR BILL- AND SO WE HAVE
BEEN HAVING GO- CONVERSATIONS-
ON THIS FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF. BUT AS AS WE ALL KNOW WE
WEAR FOR A FACING THE- HOUSE OF
ORIGIN DEADLINE FOR TO YOUR
BILLS- AND SO THAT IS OUR OUR
CURRENT SITUATION- YOU KNOW WE
ARE HOPING. THAT IS OFTEN DONE
WITH BILLS- IN IN OUR- HOUSE
THAT- THAT WITH THE
DEMONSTRATION OF GOOD FAITH AND
MEETING THE COMMITMENTS THAT WE
CAN. MOVE THE BILL FORWARD-
THAT IS FOR UP TO THIS
COMMITTEE SO I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S AWESOME. I WAS
CURIOUS WHY IN A YEAR AND A
HALF WE HAVE HAD THESE
AMENDMENTS. IF THIS IS THE VOTE
OF THE MEMBERS THAT WE NEEDED
TO GET THE VOTES OUT OF
COMMITTEE THEN WHY ARE WE THERE
AND I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR THE
OPPOSITION. I'M KIND OF THEIR
PERSPECTIVE ON WHY WHY WOULD
YOU I'M IN THIS THING THROUGH
WHAT'S WHAT'S GOINGON OUT
THERE THAT WE'RE NOT SEEING.
THAT THIS IN A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO SHE HAITIANS WERE DOWN TO
THIS FINAL COMMITTEE HEARING.
TO MOVE THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
WELL I. PERHAPS I CAN TURN OVER
TO MISLEAD. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SOME WOMEN FLORA- WE
HAD OUR FIRST CONVERSATION WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE SUPPORTERS
OF THE BILL IN DECEMBER AND
RECEIVED- AN INITIAL LIST OF
THE THIRTEEN CHEMICALS THAT YOU
SEE HERE ON FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
AND FRANKLY WE TOOK BACK BACK
TO OUR MEMBER COMPANIES AND
THEY SAID- THAT. THAT'S A MAJOR
IMPROVEMENT OVER THE ORIGINAL
BILL AND PRINT. AND THEN WE ASK
FOR THE REST OF THE BILL AND
SIX DAYS BEFORE CHRISTMAS WE
WERE GIVEN THE REST OF THE BILL
WHICH BEFORE IT YES TM
COMMITTEE HAD HUGE BACK DOORS
FOR DPH TO ADD ADDITIONAL
CHEMICALS THAT WILL. WITH NO
SCIENTIFIC REVIEW NO RISK
ASSESSMENTS AND OBVIOUSLY THAT
WAS A HUGE BECAUSE OF CONCERNS.
AND SO WE MADE THE APPEAL ANY
SEM COMMITTEE TO FULLY ALIGNED
THIS WITH. YOU AND- WE THOUGHT
THAT WE HAD THAT AGREEMENT
UNTIL. TWENTY FOUR HOURS AGO
AND I'M NOT. PLACING THIS ON
THE AUTHOR SO- I HOPE THIS
IMAGE EACH YEAR NOT. I'M NOT
QUESTIONING YOUR INTEGRITY AT
ALL- BUT- FOLKS THAT ARE
WORKING ON YOUR BILL. ALLUDED
TO THE FACT THAT THEY CAN NOT.
MADE IN THE S. HIM TO FULLY
ALIGNED THIS WITH THE E. U.
WHICH OBVIOUSLY AT THIS POLICY
JUNCTURE. CAUSES A SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS AND I WOULD
JUST WHAT EVERY STATE MY
COMMITMENT AND THE COMMITMENT
OF MY ENTIRE COALITION. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO THE SPIRIT OF THIS
BILL WE'RE COMMITTED TO FULLY
ALIGNING WITH THE E. U. AND WE
COMMIT. IF WHATEVER THE
COMMITTEE DECIDES TO DO TODAY
WE COMMIT TO GOING BACK TO THE
TABLE TO FULLY ALIGN THIS WITH
THE E. U. AS RESEARCH I MEAN AS
A FATHER OF TWO LITTLE GIRLS I
ACTUALLY WANT TO VOTE ON A BILL
LIKE THIS. IDEA I MEAN THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
HOUSE I APPRECIATE YOU BRING
ABOARD I AM I JUST BE LAYING
OFF OF THIS TODAY. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING SOMETHING AND
FUTURE. THANK YOU. WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I UNDERSTAND THAT-
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION YOU KNOW UPON THIS
BILL FROM BOTH SIDES TRYING TO
GET TO PROGRESS TOWARDS THE
SOLUTION THAT CAN BE AGREED
UPON I APPLAUD BOTH SIDES FOR
WORKING TOGETHER ON THIS- YOU
KNOW. AS SOMEONE WHO- IS A HUGE
SUPPORTER OF NATURAL PRODUCTS
AND YOU KNOW NOBODY WANTS TO
SEE THE CHEMICALS ESPECIALLY
THE CHEMICALS ON THE LIST IN
THESE PRODUCTS THAT WE'RE
PUTTING ON OUR SKIN INTERFACE-
SO. EVEN ONE OF THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT I ALWAYS THINK
ABOUT IS THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW
I LOOK AT THINGS LIKE THE
FORMALDEHYDE AND HAIR
STRAIGHTENERS AND- A FEW YEARS
AGO I HAD LOOKED INTO THAT AND
THERE IS A FROM ALL THE HYPE
FREE OPTION BUT IT COSTS OVER A
HUNDRED DOLLARS MORE THAN THE
ONE THAT HAS THE FORMALDEHYDE
IN IT. SO YOU LOOK AT MAKE UP
ON THE COUNTER AND THE LOWER
COSTS MAKE UPS TEND TO HAVE
MORE THAN ARGUABLY THERE SOME
SUBSTITUTES BUT THE TEN HAVE
MORE OF THE CHEMICALS IN THEM
THAN THE ONES YOU COULD PAY
MORE FOR A GOLDEN NORDSTROM AND
GET THE HIGH END PRODUCTS THAT
MAYBE DON'T HAVE SOME OF THOSE
OR YOU CAN PICK AND CHOOSE
THEM- YOU KNOW BUT IT'S REALLY
A SOCIO ECONOMIC THING TOO WE
LOOKING AT DISADVANTAGED WOMEN
AND YOU KNOW COMMUNITIES THAT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN HAVE SAFE PRODUCTS FOR
EVERYBODY ACROSS THE SOCIO
ECONOMIC- FRAMEWORK SO. IT'S AN
ISSUE THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT I
THINKWE ALL AGREE THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT. SO THE AMENDMENTS
THE AUTHOR PLANS TO TAKE AN
APPROACH. TO ADDRESS MANY OF
THE REMAINING CONCERNS THERE'S
OTHER ISSUES THAT WE'RE HEARING
FROM THE OPPOSITION. BUT YOU
KNOW ONCE AGAIN BECAUSE OF
THESE DEADLINES IT'S KIND OF
BEING PUSHED- SO I'M GOING TO
LAY OFF THE BILL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THESE
AMENDMENTS ACTUALLY IMPRINT.
AND HAVE SUFFICIENT TIME TO
ANALYZE SOME. THERE'S ALSO TIME
TO HAVE A NEW BILL THAT CAN
COME OUT AND CONTINUE ON AND I
THINK THAT MIGHT BE THE
CLEANEST WAY TO DO IT IN THIS
YOU KNOW BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
AN ISSUE THAT WE DO NEED TO
ADDRESS AND CONTINUE TO WORK
FOR SO- I HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT A BILL WHEN IT COMES
YOU KNOW TO US EITHER ON THE
FLOOR MAYBE BACK AS A NEW BILL-
THAT IS CLEANER AND IN A LINE
WITH THE E. U. AND- THAT DEALS
WITH SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND
CAN HELP DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MISTER IS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IS THERE
A MOTION TO MOVE THE. GOD LIKE
TO MAKE THE MOTION FIRST.
SECOND OF ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SECOND OF ALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
WORK. ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I'VE
WORKED ON NUMEROUS TO YOUR
BILLS- I'VE WORKED ON. NUMEROUS
MULTI YOUR BILLS- AND IT'S
INTERESTING HOW SOME OF THE
ARGUMENTS COME BACK. AND
PROCESS BECOMES THE ENEMY OF
SOMETHING GOODTHAT'S BEING
ATTEMPTED TO MOVE FORWARD-
MISLI I DO APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING BACK SOME OF YOUR
COMMENTS FROM THE- FROM THE
ASSEMBLY AUTHOR. HE DIDN'T
APPRECIATE THE INITIAL OPENING
STATEMENTS BECAUSE FOR AS- MANY
YEARS AS I'VE WORKED WITH THE
AUTHOR SINCE I'VE BEEN FIRST
ELECTED- HE'S SHOWN NOTHING BUT
GREAT INTEGRITY. AND I DON'T
APPRECIATE ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES.
BEING SPOKEN OF IN A WAY WHERE-
I KNEW HIS TRUE INTENTION AND I
KNOW WHY HE'S TRYING TO DO
THIS- I CAME HERE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY. SO I PLAN ON
VOTING FOR IT. DISAPPOINTED
WITH WHERE THE CONVERSATION HAS
BEEN GOING. KIND OF REMINDS ME
OF THE CIGARETTE BILLS THE HOST
OF CIGARETTE TOBACCO BILLS THAT
WE WERE WORKING ON SEVERAL
YEARS AGO AND- THEY WERE ALL
HELD SO WE NEEDED A SPECIAL
SESSION TO ACTUALLY MOVING
FORWARD. AND WE GOT IT DONE
THAT WAY. I HAVE EVERY FAITH IN
THE AUTHOR'S WORDS WHEN HE SAYS
THAT HE'S GOING TO BE WORKING
ON THIS BILL. AND THREE DAYS IS
JUST NOT ENOUGH TIME TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES IN. THE.
PRECISION THAT NEEDS TO GO
NGUYEN TO SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO BECOME LAW. SO FOR THE
BENEFIT OF- THE TRUST I HAVE IN
WHAT HE'S SAYING AS WELL AS MY
COLLEAGUES- IN WANTING TO SEE
SOMETHING. UP MOVE FORWARD
THAT'S GOING TO BE A BENEFIT
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND
PROBABLY LEAD THE WAY IN THE
NATION. I ACTUALLY WANT TO SEE
THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD AND WE
HAVE AND THEN GIVE THE TIME
NEEDS NECESSARY. TO WORK ON THE
BILL. AND IF IT DOESN'T MEET
THE COMMITMENT STANDARDS THAT
THE AUTHOR HAD. MADE. THEN WE
HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO NOT
VOTE FOR IT ON THE FLOOR. BUT
THIS IS I DON'T LIKE SEEING THE
PROCESS BE USED TO SLOW DOWN.
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
MEANINGFUL SO. I WILL BE VOTING
ON THIS BILL I DO HOPE IT COMES
UP FOR A VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE SEE OTHER
COMMENTS THE SCRIPT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR FOR ADDRESSING A LOT
OF THE CONCERNS- THAT THE
MEMBERS HAVE AD. WITH THE
PROCESS I THINK IN INSIDE
CONVERSATIONS. ANNOUNCER HARD
AND TAKE TIME. THIS IS A VERY
COMPLICATED BILL WE'RE TRYING
TO GET ONE STATE OUR STATE TO
LEAD THE WAY ACROSS THE NATION
WHEN IT COMES TO CHEMICALS AND
COSMETICS. THAT LEAD TO A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT HEALTH
ISSUES. I AM VERY HAPPY AND
PLEASED TO HEAR THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS IN AGREEMENT AND
WANTS TO GET TO A BETTER PLACE
WHEN IT COMES TO CAUSE MEDICS.
I THINK THE FRUSTRATION IS
THAT. THIS IS A HUGELY
IMPORTANT BILL AND THERE HASN'T
BEEN A LOT OF TIME TO REVIEW
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE WORKING
VERY HARD AND EVEN IN THE THREE
DAYS SINCE THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE. TO GET TO THE
AMENDMENTS AND TO GET TO THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE WANTED TO SEE
IS COMMENDABLE ON YOUR END- I
SIT ON APPROPRIATIONS SO I WILL
HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW THIS BILL- I THINK THAT
WE WANT TO GET TO A PLACE IN
WHICH POLICY DECISIONS AND
LANGUAGE ARE MADE AND POLICY
COMMITTEES AND NOT ENOUGH
FISCAL COMMITTEE. AND I THINK
THAT'S I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING FROM A LOT OF OUR
COLLEAGUES- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL IN GOOD
FAITH. WITH YOU. BUT I REALLY
DO HOPE THAT YOU GET TO A PLACE
WITH THE OPPOSITION- INTO
ACTUALLY GETTING CALIFORNIA AND
TO EAT YOU STANDARDS IF THAT IS
THE INTENT- BUT I THINK MOVING
FORWARD. THIS IS A REAL GOOD
OPPORTUNITY I THINK FOR ALL OF
US TO THINK ABOUT PROCESS
DEADLINES. I ALSO HAVE TO YOUR
BILLS THAT I HAVE DECIDED TO
HOLD OFF AND ACTUALLY RE
INTRODUCE. BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO. I WANT TO GET MY COLLEAGUES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW. AND
TO ACTUALLY HAVE A THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION. THINGS THAT ARE%
INCREDIBLY HEAVY TO LEFT- AND
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD AS A STATUS AND IF
CALIFORNIA IS TO LEAD THE WAY
AND THEN WE NEED ALL OF US ON
BOARD- AND SO. AGAIN I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IN GOOD FAITH AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING SOME OF
THE ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS AND
CONCLUSIONS BE DONE AND
APPROPRIATIONS. BUT I WOULD
ALSO HOPE. THAT THIS DOES NOT
COME TO A FLOOR FIGHT. THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE WANT TO DO- WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES AS WELL. SO I
HOPE THAT WERE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
COME TO A RESOLUTION AS TO
WHERE YOU NEED TO BE. AND WHERE
ARE THE OPPOSITION ALSO NEEDS
TO BE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. FIRST OF
THANK YOU MISTER SU CHI AND
SPONSORS FOR BRING THE BILL
FORWARD- THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL IS PROBABLY PROTECTION
ESPECIALLY FOR MILLIONS OF
WOMEN AND CHILDREN WHO USE
COSMETICS IS AND STATE AND
BEAUTY PRODUCTS ON A DAILY
BASIS. AND ALTHOUGH YOU'RE
REMOVING THE PROVISIONS BANNING
LEAD IN THIS BEST US AND
DESIRED BILL TO GET TO THE VOTE
I PERSONALLY WOULD SUPPORT NOT
DOING THAT BECAUSE I THINK AS
MR MCCARTY MENTION THOSE ARE
THE THOSE ARE TO BE CLIENTS
AND- THE RISKS ARE VERY VERY%
HIGH BUT I UNDERSTAND AND
SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO- IN THE SAKE OF TRYING TO
MAKE PROGRESS ON ON ON A
DIFFICULT ISSUE. LAST YEAR A
JURY IN NEW YORK AWARDED ONE
PLAINTIFF THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS-
AGAINST JOHNSON JOHNSON ON A
CLAIM THAT IT'S BABY POWDER
BECAUSE- MESOTHELIOMA NOW THE
JURY IN SAINT LOUIS AWARDED
TWENTY TWO WENT WHEN I WOMEN
AND THEIR FAMILIES FOUR POINT
SIX NINE BILLION DOLLARS
PROCLAIMS OF THIS BESTEST IN
JOHNSON JOHNSON'S TAPPED OUT
PRODUCTS BECAUSE A VERY AND
CANCER- CURRENTLY THERE OVER.
SIXTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
HEALTH RELATED. LAWSUITS
PENDING. THESE LAWSUITS PROOF
WE CANNOT IGNORE- THE PUBLIC
KARMA SO SEE WITH. SOME
CHEMICALS- DEPOSITION CLAIMS
THE BEAUTY INDUSTRY GENERATES
BILLIONS IN OUR ECONOMY AND
THAT IS CORRECT I HAVE NO
REASON TO DOUBT THAT- IN FACT
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
UNITED STATES WAS CONSIDERED
THE MOST PROFITABLE. A BEAUTY
INDUSTRY MARKET- GENERATING
EIGHTY NINE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUE- BECAUSE
YOU'RE MAKING BILLION SOME
PROFIT. THEY SHOULD BEAR THE
BURDEN IN MY OPINION OF
PRODUCING COSMETICS OR SAFE FOR
CONSUMERS. THE BILL IS NOT
ASKING MANUFACTURERS TO CHANGE
THEIR MANUFACTURING PROCESS
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN DOING THIS
IN EUROPE. FOR YEARS- IN MY
MIND WHEN THEY MANUFACTURE AND
SELL IN EUROPE THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO MANUFACTURE AND SELL
THE SAME PRODUCTS IN OUR
COUNTRY- I WILL BE VOTING YES-
WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
BILL'S WITH FOURTH. ROW ALSO
SAY THIS YOU KNOW I'M WORKING
ON A TO YOUR BILL IT'S
DIFFICULT I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
IT SINCE THE FALL- AND THERE
WILL BE CHANGES THAT HAPPEN-
VERY YOU KNOW AT THE VERY END
BECAUSE THESE SOMETIMES
CONTENTIOUS BILLS TAKE TIME. TO
REALLY WORK OUT- AND- I THINK
WE ALL KNOW THAT. I THINK WE'VE
SEEN THAT- I THINK OF I THINK
BACK TO CAP AND TRADE
NEGOTIATIONS AND THINGS THAT WE
DIDN'T KNOW. REALLY WHERE WE
WERE GOING TO BE ON THAT WE
KIND OF HAD AN IDEA- AND WE HAD
WE TOOK SOME DIFFICULT VOTES WE
PUT OUR FAITH. IN THE AUTHORS
WE PUT OUR FAITH IN THE PROCESS
I'M BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY AT AT THESE BILLS
SO- I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS
TODAY. IT THE BILL- GOES TO
THIS IF THE BILL MAKES IT TO
THE SENATE AND COMES BACK HERE-
IT TO THE FLOOR PROCESS WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY IF THE BILL HAS
CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY TO A
POINT WHERE WE'RE NOT THRILLED
THAT WE CAN PULL IT BACK TO
THIS COMMITTEE- AFTER IT LEAVES
THE SENATE- BUT YOU HAVE A
LONG. OBVIOUSLY HAVE A LONG
WAYS TO GO. SO I SAY SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY-
MISTER MURATSUCHI WHICH WHAT
CLOTHES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE TO ALL OF THE
COMMENTS- GOD MADE TODAY AND-
YOU KNOW JUST AS I HOPE THAT I
HAVE. DEMONSTRATED MY GOOD
FAITH TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO COME UP WITH THE
BILL. TO GET BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL- I HOPE THAT I
CAN COUNT ON YOUR GOOD FAITH
TO- SEE THIS IMPORTANT-
CONSUMER PROTECTION- BEING
ENACT ENACTED HOPEFULLY. YOU
KNOW SOONER. RATHER THAN LATER
AND WITH THAT I ASKED FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION- FROM WESTERN IS ARIANNA
SECOND FOR MISTER MCCARTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD I'D MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY NOT
VOTING BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT
VOTING BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE.
BURKE NOT VOTING CARILLO RIO I
AM FLORA. FLORA NOT VOTING LOW
MOAN MOAN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I
IN THIS AREA IN. NAZARIAN AYE
RAMOS RAMOS NOT VOTING
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
WATER NOT VOTING. SAID WHEN YOU
HAVE SEVEN VOTES SENSE I'M
FORTY NOT ENOUGH VOTES. ALRIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
TEAMS. FOR SAY THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE TODAY-
THAT WITH THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND CLOSE THE BUSINESS OF THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. THANK YOU